l'actualité en france est également
dominée par un procès très attendu celui
des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
quatrième jour toujours autant d'émotion
la cour a commencé à projeter des photos
des scènes d'horreur des enregistrements
sonores également seront à diffuser des
moments redouté par les victimes les
précisions avec à notre reporter katia
technique depuis le palais de justice à
paris
les enquêteurs viennent durant deux
jours d'écrire les premières
constatations réalisées sur les scènes
de crime hier ils ont raconté les scènes
relatives aux attentats en dehors du
stade de france où trois kamikazes se
sont fait exploser
4 - en tout dont les trois terroristes
un chauffeur de car puis ils ont décrit
des scènes d'horreur du petit cambodge
du carillon 13 morts et de la bonne
bière et casa nostra cinq morts les
enquêteurs n'ont pas à dissimuler leurs
émotions ils auraient toujours très
difficile de raconter ces scènes
d'horreur ils se sont attachés aussi à
montrer la puissance de feu des armes
des centaines de munitions tirées à
l'armé de guerre 121 d'où il tirait en
deux minutes 31 aux terrasses du
carillon par exemple et des dégâts
considérables entraînée par les
explosions qui étaient chargés en écrou
alors parlons de la nécessité ou non de
montrer des images et qu'elles sont
allées bien par exemple celle de la
police sur la scène de crime ou encore
des images de vidéosurveillance de la
ville de paris alors pour ce qui est des
vidéos en réalité elles sont diffusées
sans le son pour minimiser évidemment
leur impact et sur les photos par
exemple les bouts de corps du stade de
france ont été masquées par des carrés
blancs l'idée étant de montrer pour
faire comprendre l'intensité de la scène
de la figure et dans l'espace dans sa
dynamique mais avec une grande pudeur ce
sera la même chose cet après midi avec
les vidéos du bataclan une vidéo sera
projetée du début de la fusillade mais
elle sera très rapide et sans le son est
d'ailleurs hier les parties civiles
qu'on a averti à l'avancé pour qu'elle
puisse quitter la salle ne sont pas
sortis donc il y a beaucoup de respect
ici pour la sensibilité des victimes qui
sont venus en nombre aujourd'hui pour
une journée douloureuse qui s'annonce
avec les constatations de la scène de
crime du bataclan